JDI get wealthy what do you think about
storytelling in marketing so I just
wanna make sure I understand the
question too and I don't know if he's on
here if you can reach out but well by
storytelling out thinking you mean
content the content that you're
providing to your audience yeah I would
I would I would assume so okay I mean
the things that you want to look at when
you're starting to create or write or
send down any content is start looking
at the type of keywords that if you have
Google Analytics or any type of other
analytical tool that you might be using
look at certain keywords that people are
responding to right so for us we look at
things like email automation email
marketing the other thing is if you've
put out other types of content in the
past get in the habit of tagging every
piece of content you put out there when
I say tagging with Google Analytics you
have four dimensions right so a source
medium campaign name to that content you
should be providing a tag for each piece
of content so you can understand what's
being more receptive to your audience
right so who is reading your blog post
or anything along those lines and same
thing with email marketing if you're
sending out certain types of newsletters
or pieces of broadcast you always want
to make sure that you're understanding
how people are reacting to it and you
just want to try to follow that type of
pattern throughout the course of your
business honestly throughout the end of
time if possible yes storytelling is
super important you know we before we
got on this call we're talking about
Star Wars and how Michael has to wait
till Wednesday before you can see it
like it's just a great story right has
built a multi-billion dollar industry I
think your advantage as an entrepreneur
is your story the way that you stand out
the way you compete against the huge
companies in the industry is your story
like why don't you do this let me feel
your passion because if if you are doing
you know the same thing as a big
competitor and you want to offer the
same price why would I ever go with you
right I'm gonna go with somebody else
that has the brand name the recognition
the trust so then you have to cut your
price which isn't the business that you
want to begin so the difference is your
ability to tell your story
is if I feel your passion about what
you're doing and I can relate to you
then I'm much more likely to want to buy
from you and I think too many
entrepreneurs hide behind a corporate
looking website because it looks
professional put your picture on your
website tell us why you started this
thing right in your email campaign let
me feel your your passion right like one
of the emails should say why you started
this business and why you're so excited
about it when you're providing content
tell me your personal take on it right
not just here the facts and figures but
tell me what it means to you
that's your ability to create a personal
relationship with people that will then
convert really well to building trust
and then to closing clients